investigators in Michigan continue
searching for the remains of up to seven
girls this morning they're following
leads from the man who they believe
killed all of the children 69 year old
Arthur Remus's name he is serving life
in prison for the murder of 13 year old
Cindy Czar's if Kate Moore Cindy's our
Zeki is her name more than three decades
ago Niki Bateses in Macomb Township
Michigan that's outside Detroit with the
effort to finally solve these cold cases
Niki good morning good morning in 2008
arthur ream led authorities to this area
where they found the remains of Cindy
SARS Ikki now investigators are back and
this time they believe seven missing
girls may be buried on this land
I remember what your face looks like I
remember the toy there you did exist
Cathy Lucas hopes that after nearly four
decades she will finally get answers as
to what happened to her little sister
Kimberly King King disappeared after
leaving a friend's house in 1979 when
she was 12 years old whatever happened
to her happened to her from a stranger
you know whatever happened to her was
not planned whatever happened to her she
didn't see it coming for the last two
days the FBI and police have been
searching through this area in Macomb
Township Michigan where they believe
King and six other young girls may be
buried police said they were led to the
area after spending months interviewing
convicted killer Arthur Reem Warren
Police Commissioner Bill Dwyer spoke to
WWJ radio station in Detroit we believe
our dreams was the person that committed
the murders what we're trying to do is
bring closure to the families of the
victims
hidden camera footage from Detroit
station WDIV appears to show Reem about
a decade ago confessing to killing 13
year old Cindy SARS iki she went missing
in 1986 in another video he tells
investigators where he buried her body
in 2008 Rheem led investigators to SARS
Ickes body in a field in Macomb Township
it's near the same area they are combing
through now when Rheem was charged with
SARS Ickes murder he was already in
prison for sexually assaulting a young
girl investigators have not said yet if
they have found any remains and police
previously said this search could take
between two and four days Nikki thank
you this is so disturbing for so many
families and yet I hope maybe it would
bring them some closure I was thinking
the exact same thing all the years of
not knowing if not now I appreciated